>> The brainstorming session assumes that
there was, in fact, a market
failure, a huge market failure, a failure
of the regularty system and
that you had this burn psychology that meant
that people thought you
could leverage-- from date endlessly and that
it was stainable.
But more became real issue is who's gonna
share the blame, who's
gonna stand up and say we were responsible.
We apologize and take the consequences.
In a reality of a sector there are rules of
law.
But here working people are the victims of
the system that was simply
about casino capitalism and yet here at Davos
today as a labor leader
on continued we could no body take the blame.
It is absolutely horrendous that 50 million
more unemployed people will
be the victims of a financial system that
got out of whack because
people were basically hooked on greed.
We need to make sure that the resources are
distributed more over
equivocally that working people not only have
jobs but the decent jobs,
the jobs where they have rights, collective
bargaining rights,
and that there is a frame work for global
regulation, not just national
but global regulation, that sees this could
never happen again.
So there's a little bit more need for-- humility
for or honesty and
acknowledgement that the financial leaders,
the corporate leaders who
played into that financial environment got
it wrong.